y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
lo que nos criamos en ciudades chicas
estoy seguro que alguna dirigimos
no hay nada para hacer un trabajo
estable de la manera cambio le gustaría
y ojos ahí siempre aparece en escena una
persona por lo general ya entrada en
años cambios y con una panza acorde a su
experiencia sí no
querían recordarnos que todo tiempo
pasado fue mejor
es realmente esto así
o tal vez no sabemos aprovechar lo que
la realidad tiene para ofrecernos
al pensar en esto inevitablemente me
acuerdo de mis amigos de toda la vida y
juantxo francos y emanuel estas fotos
que también hay es del año 2009 cuando
íbamos a la secundaria
que les puedo decir de mis amigos que
los quiero muchísimo que son como mis
hermanos y que son tres personas
supercapaces que como no contaban con
los recursos necesarios como para poder
quedarse como para el poder espero que
les gustaba
se quedaron acá en la ciudad
y vaya sorpresa hasta el día de hoy no
pueden conseguir un trabajo que les
permita aproximarse a cumplir sus sueños
en cuanto a mí que soy el cuarto en esta
foto la marca de la ausencia de
oportunidades también se hizo presente
mis riesgos que son trabajadores
hicieron un esfuerzo sobrehumano para
que yo pudiera estudiar lo que me
gustaba
porque sabía que yo también lo sabía que
si me quedaba en la ciudad
voy a estudiar algo pero probablemente
mi futuro como persona iba a estar por
toda oportunidad
alguna vez alguno de ustedes se preguntó
por qué pasar estas cosas
vivimos en pleno siglo 21 estamos en el
medio de este fenómeno que conocemos
como la globalización
en el que los sucesos y los avances sean
con una diversidad que nos sorprenda a
todos y derriban las fronteras y las
barreras que existen entre las personas
en este contexto
las ciudades para acertadas es más y más
importantes vamos al sincero son nuestro
hogar y las creamos y las recreamos a
cada paso de nuestra existencia
se estima que para el año 2050 un 68% de
la población mundial va a vivir en una
ciudad
por si ese número no le suena tendría
ser casi siete de cada diez personas en
todo el mundo
siete de cada diez
si cada vez más personas eligen vivir en
ciudades quiere decir que allí es donde
tenemos mayores posibilidades de
progresar
qué es lo que explica entonces esteban
mientras algunas ciudades parecen cannes
en el tiempo
otras progresan son vibrantes todo el
mundo quiere visitarlas y todo el mundo
queremos vivir en ellas
acá les voy a contar una palabra clave y
es que la vaca cuando salgan por esa
puerta para volver a sus casas esta
estrategia
si queremos que la globalización nos
sirva a la ciudad para traernos más
oportunidades a las personas necesitamos
salir estratégicamente al mundo
parte de mi preocupación como futuro
profesional en el campo de las
relaciones internacionales pasa
justamente por esto por conectar a las
ciudades con las oportunidades que el
mundo tiene para expresarnos no de
manera indiscriminada sino acentuando
nuestras fortalezas nuestras
potencialidades y tratando de disminuir
el impacto que el mundo puede llegar a
tener sobre nuestras características más
vulnerables
como se ve todo eso es total lindo que
les estoy contando en la vida real a
través de los proyectos concretos que
mejoran la calidad de vida de la
población y evitar la migración hacia
otros lugares en busca de un futuro
mejor
otra vez inevitablemente en alguno de
ellos de mis amigos
esta es una foto de hace unos meses
atrás y a simple vista se puede notar un
par de cosas por empezar nos sumamos un
quinto amiga amigos y en el grupo tal y
cual es las bebidas alcohólicas
en segundo lugar también formó así que
sea una especie de relación inversamente
proporcional con ella que va mejorando
la calidad de las fotos de los teléfonos
los que estamos en eso algunos tienen un
par de kilos de más
nosotros tenemos que hacer mella pero
sabes qué es lo que compartimos al día
de hoy más allá del profundo afecto que
tenemos nosotros
las marcas de las faldas de
oportunidades
francos por ejemplo es el que también
derecha meta poco
fue campeón nacional de las olimpiadas
de geografía en el año 2012 campeón
nacional
hoy en día la profesora de geografía no
tiene tiempo porque tiene que estar de
lunes a lunes trabajando simplemente
para poder vivir
después tenga juancho es el que está a
mi izquierda mayor que justo ayer a su
tienda
cuando quería estudiar algo relacionado
de ámbito de defensa para poder entrar
en una de las fuerzas de seguridad de
nuestro país pero como no contaba con
esa posibilidad que desde entonces van
cambiando de carrera en carrera sin
poder encontrar lo que a él realmente le
apasiona y tampoco puede conseguir un
trabajo que le permita una cierta
independencia económica
por último está manual que es un genio
en computación perdonada en los genios
la cual tiene cosas pero en cuenta todo
todo el día trabajando en su local que
construyó desde la nada misma
a la facultad a estudiar programación y
no puede desarrollar su potencial y
seguir aprendiendo lo que le gusta
porque no cuenta con las herramientas
necesarias por falta de presupuesto la
universidad
y podría programación y no tiene ni los
programas necesarios en la computadora
para poder estudiar
lo peor de todo esto es estoy contando
y es que nosotros como jóvenes no
tenemos nada que nos salga menos que el
resto del mundo absolutamente nada
recientemente tuve la inmensa fortuna de
ser elegido entre el selecto grupo de
ocho jóvenes líderes a nivel mundial
para participar de un seminario de una
semana en nueva delhi la capital de
india
ya que en representación de la argentina
fue el único argentino en ese evento y
de más está decir que fue una
experiencia increíble o sea me vuela la
cabeza
aprendí muchísimo pero si hay dos cosas
que me gustaría compartir con ustedes
son las siguientes
número 1 hay misiones
nunca lo voy a poder decir con el
énfasis suficiente para que ustedes
puedan entenderlo hay millones de
oportunidades allá afuera para todos los
gustos y para todos los colores
hay dieta de puntos encontradas no
vienen solas
y números
pero no menos importante nuestros
recursos humanos como argentinos son
brillantes no tenemos nada que
envidiarle a mejor estadounidenses ni a
los chinos ni a nadie
saben que no que los diferencia a ellos
que nosotros nos veremos que tienen un
estado que está ahí presente para salir
al mundo y traerles oportunidades a
ellos para que puedan desarrollarse
otra vez queremos mejores ciudades
salgamos estratégicamente al mundo
recuerdo cuando llegué por primera vez a
rosario
para estudiar con tres días para cumplir
18 años
con muchísimo miedo
esto nunca lo puede contar en público
porque me es muy difícil pero todo lo
que me rodea saber por todo lo que tuvo
que pasar
es muy difícil dejar tu ciudad que es tu
hogar es como dejar un pedazo de tu
corazón hasta el día de hoy lo siento
así ya pasaron casi 6 años
para que esto donde pase a vos
y a tus amigos ni a nadie que conoces es
necesario brindarle herramientas a
nuestros jóvenes para que se queden en
sus ciudades y puedan crecer desde allí
al fin y al cabo quien más lindo que
darle alas
y con una estrategia lo podemos hacer
imagínense lo brillante que hubiera sido
franco
si se hubiera podido dedicar
completamente a la geografía
o juancho que a día de hoy estuviera en
un país
los padres no están lejos en manual si
tuviera los programas necesarios para
producir atendiendo lo que le gusta
así
así se verá falta de oportunidades
por si todo esto
que les estoy contando no les parece
argumento suficiente
un ejemplo más
mira
mira bien
este
ese tatuaje que me hice cuando por fin
pude superar la profunda depresión
clínica en la que cada ciudad
tras dos intentos de suicidio
e innumerables secuelas sicológicas que
me gustó muchísimo muchísimos superar
si queremos que estas cosas dejen de
pasar tenemos que salir estratégicamente
por favor no le pongamos un punto final
en la ciudad es muchas gracias
[Aplausos]